oui comme partout en france ici à vesoul
cet appel à la grève et à la
manifestation des syndicats de la
fonction publique pour la défense de la
fonction publique mais ici à vesoul
cette manifestation prend un caractère
un peu particulier avec les salariés de
chez psa puisque le groupe souhaite
justement augmenté la semaine de travail
la faire passer de 35 heures à 37 heures
45 ce qui est non pour les syndicats
nous en avons rencontré quelques-uns
quelques manifestants ce matin qu'ils
étaient présents ici à vesoul et même
des salariés de l usine de sochaux qui
était venu en soutien de leurs collègues
de bezouce ce qui est leur couronne est
injustifiée et pas normal qu'en mais
qu'est ce qui se dit à sochaux qu'est ce
qui dit dans les autres usines du groupe
par rapport à ici s'il est si la porte
est ouverte à vesoul elle peut arriver à
sochaux elle peut arriver dans les
otites donc ça notre crainte et il n'y a
rien qui justifie cette augmentation du
temps de travail injustifiés comme ils
veulent nous faire que ça fait trois
jours de suite que les gars ps à vesoul
débrayent et ça c'est inédit qui va se
passer dans les prochains jours donc
dans les prochains jours on va déjà voir
ce après midi ce que ça donne parce
qu'encore démobilisation fally
rassemblement cet après midi et après on
va
repartez de l'argumentaire pour voir
quelle suite donner au mouvement
vesoul la direction nous demande de
travailler 33 minutes par jour en plus
et payer 12 minutes et nous villa
vis-à-vis des salariés
je suis là moi pas pour dire non n'est
pas on veut pas travailler gratuitement
une modification du temps de travail qui
fait débat le groupe psa annoncé des
réunions de travail avec les partenaires
sociaux des réunions de négociation la
première est prévue aujourd'hui elles
devraient s'échelonner en tout il y en
aura quatre
elles devraient s'échelonner jusqu'à
début juin